[Music]
hi sir can I help you
hi I've been having some really bad
stomach pains and I wonder if there was
a doctor that could see me right now of
course just make a lot and he'll see you
right away I've been having really bad
stomach pains I was wondering if there's
a doctor that could see me right now
fill these forms out I'll get to weekend
[Music]
[Music]
don't worry I've got you hello
[Music]
alright everyone we've got a parcel
colectomy such a waste in here so let's
get him prepped and start the incision
but this shirt looks kind of nice and
expensive let's get this off of nicely
and laundered
when he gets out of here
[Music]
just tell me how bad is it I'm sorry to
say in spite of your mild symptoms you
only have a few hours to live just tell
me how bad is it it's just a mild cold
you'll be fine in a few days
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
health grades and it looks like your
insurance covered everything so all we
need from you is a $10 copay green bill
of health
congratulations that'll be $40,000 do
you validate parking
of course
[Music]